wait wait so after the free throws oh  wow Eric Gordon suck I always wanna get  down on loony called on the foul talk  about not settling for the three which  he's been doing in this series let's  take it all the way to the rack here  between two warriors Looney on his back  thank you David there's part with the  dry lake shore unchanged pardon going  right at Tremont green and a lot of  chatter out there  [Applause]  anything else you want to say don't  stake back to the party  yes  continue uses my spot  [Applause]  Wow then we have two posters tonight one  by heart you're green and how about this  the sneaky hops left-handed finish by  Livingston and that's how you have to  attack the basket  [Applause]  top circle time  couple of possibilities here that can be  a casting shoot for a tie for Golden  State or houston commit a channel as  Livingston inbound  but do it